um what's the millennial question
apparently Millennials as a generation
which is a group of people who were born
approximately 1984 and after
are tough to manage about how
Millennials present themselves
physically in an interview they come
overly casually dressed you know maybe a
young man doesn't wear a tie and lower
rates of employment overall they have
um lower earnings lower savings and then
layered on top of that they have debt
we've all heard it the idea that
Millennials are worse off than any
generation before them 59 can't afford a
thousand dollar emergency expense most
Millennials can't afford a home and many
are still living with their parents
nearly 75 percent of million dollars are
living paycheck to paycheck at 70 of
them plan to leave their jobs and on and
on and on this widespread belief paints
all Millennials as being broke lazy and
downright financially illiterate and
that all of this is thanks to the
Boomers in government and the 2008
financial crisis that permanently
destroyed the economy for younger
Generations this is the mainstream
narrative but it's also complete and
utter baloney every single statistic
that you see on those headlines are
cherry-picked to push narrative consider
for example the statistic that when
Boomers were in their early 30s they
controlled it 20 percent of the national
wealth but when Millennials were in
their early 30s they only controlled
three and a half percent of the national
wealth this seems like a massive
discrepancy and it is but what most of
these studies failed to mention is the
other discrepancies that easily explain
this like demographics when Boomers were
growing up the US population was over a
hundred million less as such Boomers
made up for a lot more of the population
than Millennials did in fact when you
account for this one discrepancy the
world discrepancy not only goes away but
it actually inverts I kid you not
Millennials on a per capita basis are
actually slightly wealthier than Boomers
were at the same age but how could that
be aren't all Millennials broke bums
living with their parents well the truth
is that there's a whole another group of
Millennials that are never mentioned
that are richer than any generation
before them and I'm not talking about
some sort of elite top 0.1 percent I'm
talking about the 35 percent who have
net worth over a hundred thousand the 18
we have net Worth's over a quarter
million the nine percent who have net
worth over half a million and the three
percent who are already millionaires
also keep in mind Millennials are
predominantly in their 30s right now so
it's safe to say that a large portion of
this 35 will end up as Millionaires
multi-millionaires and a Deca
millionaires now of course being a
millionaire is already not the same and
it won't be the same in 30 years but
it's also a far cry from The Narrative
that portrays Millennials solely as
financially struggling losers that are
still reliant on their parents the
reality is that a large portion of
Millennials are actually way richer than
you think so so join me as we take a
look at how this narrative came to be
and discover the truth about Millennial
world
all right so if Millennials are actually
doing just as well as previous
generations on a per capita basis why do
they get such a bad rep is it just a
book a minority or a media bias or is
there more to it well I think we can get
a better idea when we take a look at the
wealthiest people from each generation
the average net worth of Millennials are
considered themselves wealthy is 531
thousand dollars on average malayos
needed 100 000 more than gen xers to
feel wealthy the only generation that
needed more money than Millennials to
feel wealthy was Boomers who on average
needed 692 thousand dollars but wait a
minute that means that Millennials have
lower expectations than Boomers but
aren't even able to achieve these lower
expectations because of the crony
economy right well actually no because
you have to consider that they're in
completely different stages of Life
boomers are predominantly in their 60s
meaning that their context is retirement
this means that Boomers on average think
that hundred ninety two thousand dollars
is enough for retirement that as a whole
meanwhile Millennials are wanting 531
thousand dollars as 30 year olds with 30
more years in the workforce and taking a
look at their retirement expectations
this all makes sense on average
Millennials are wanting 1.8 million
dollars for retirement or nearly triple
what boomers are looking for even high
inflation and Rising living costs don't
account for that massive disparity in
expectations but you know what does
perception wealth is a rather subjective
topic two and a half million might be
middle class in San Francisco but in
Nebraska that would be quite wealthy a
significant portion of the perception
that Millennials are financially
challenged stems from this subjectivity
in general Millennials who are
objectively well off may not consider
themselves as such reinforcing the
notion of Millennials Financial
struggles this notion is less about
their actual Financial well-being and
more about their ambitious aspirations
again let me reiterate Millennials don't
think that half a million is even enough
to be considered wealthy while Boomers
think that 700 000 is wealthy enough to
straight up retire but how does such a
massive discrepancy involve expectations
manifest between Generations well the
answer is easy social media
various Studies have found that
Millennials approach both from a
comparative basis while Boomers tend to
approach wealth from an objective basis
for example a boomer might evaluate
their financial status based on expenses
groceries taxes insurance premiums and
so on
if they can comfortably afford these
expenses for a prolonged period without
active income they tend to classify
themselves as wealthy Millennials on the
other hand don't Define a wealth based
on sustainability in fact sustainability
has nothing to do with their equation
rather they Define wealth based on what
their richest friends can do being able
to go on the same vacations live in the
same luxury buildings eat out at the
same restaurants and so on in fact 47
percent of Millennials compare their
lives to their peers on social media
while only 13 percent of Boomers compare
their lives to their Social Circles this
explains why Millennials have such a bad
financial rapid despite doing just as
well as previous generations the reality
is that 50 of Millennials are actually
just broke but the other 50 are actually
pretty well off but they would never
describe themselves as such because
their expectations are multiple times
higher than any previous generation thus
the entire generation is frequently
misrepresented as being financially
disadvantaged which isn't true
but something that is true about
Millennials is the Raging world to
divide
[Music]
the media often frames the water divide
as a conflict between the top one
percent and the rest of society however
the reality is more nuanced it's
actually a struggle between the upper 50
and the lower 50 and I think this graph
really showcases this phenomenon the top
50 of Millennials have net worth
anywhere between 46 000 and 3 million
which again is pretty good if we look at
the left side of this graph though it
gets ugly real quickly a net worth of
zero somehow puts you in the 20th
percentile meaning that nearly 1 in 5
Millennials have a negative net worth so
the middle class is indeed disappearing
but not in the way that is often
portrayed not everyone is becoming broke
the top half and especially the top
quarter are thriving in the new economy
the bottom half and especially the
bottom quarter are getting annihilated
but how do we get here people often like
to point the finger at politics and the
capitalism but I think the answer has
more to do with three social trends
starting with the 2008 financial crisis
discussions surrounding the recession
typically center around its impact on
the job market economy and opportunities
but the most important item that the
recession destroyed at least for
Millennials was their investing Spirit
that's kind of a meme that Millennials
are the degenerates gambling on options
in the AMC and nfts and all of that crap
but not actually such a small portion of
Millennials the vast majority of
Millennials are actually extremely
conservative when it comes to
investments in fact they prefer to just
hoard cash 65 percent of millennial
wealth is held in cash the highest of
any generation and much of the rest is
in real estate only a mere 15 percent is
actually invested in stocks which is
really bad when you consider that
Boomers have a 24 invested in stocks
even though they're supposed to be the
risk-averse one
the 2008 financial crisis gave
Millennials investing PTSD like no other
generation in fact 57 percent of
Millennials admit that the crisis still
influences their investing choices today
while the same is only true for 39 of
gen xers and just 13 of Boomers given
that investing is the key to not just
retirement but Financial Freedom in
general especially in terms of high
inflation it's no wonder why there's
such a wealth divide amongst Millennials
there is the half that invests and the
half that doesn't many Millennials would
argue that they just don't have enough
money to invest and this is also often
true because many of them are stuck in
mountains of college debt of course the
skyrocketing price of tuition very much
plays a role here but I believe the
crisis is more closely linked to the
relevance of Education Millennials were
strongly urged to pursue higher
education which was often touted as the
key to securing good jobs and success as
such 38 of Millennials end up up getting
a degree while only 32 percent of gen
xers and 15 of Boomers have a degree
however this has largely backfired as a
lot of Millennials ended up getting
degrees just because they were told to
do so resulting in a bunch of expensive
degrees that have no value in the job
market as such many of these Millennials
would end up getting jobs that didn't
even need a degree or paid more for a
degree making it even harder to pay off
their debt if they didn't end up in one
of these jobs it's more than likely that
they ended up in one of the new age gig
economy jobs which is even worse we're
talking food delivery ride sharing
Freelancers Etc on paper these jobs
actually have pretty good salaries but
what they don't have is any benefits
which makes them far worse a police
officer or teacher may only make 60k but
they get another 60k worth of benefits
in the form of health insurance
retirement benefits paid time off set
working hours A Better Tax situation Etc
and Uber driver making 60k on the other
hand is closer to earning minimum wage
so I think much of the millennial will
to divide can be explained by an
aversion to investing irrelevant degree
is associated with massive college debt
and the modern gig economy but with that
being said I think one factor trumps all
of these
almost the entirety of the millennial
Watts divide can be explained by one
factor and one factor alone technology
Millennials who have embraced Tech are
experiencing remarkable success while
those who have not find themselves
struggling and I'm not just talking
about coders and project managers I'm
talking about people who leverage Tech
versus people who didn't you can see
this in any profession the wealthiest
lawyers are the ones serving tech
companies not the local judges the
wealthiest teachers are the ones selling
online courses not the ones in public
schools or even Harvard professors the
wealthiest accountants are the ones
helping tech companies save on their
taxes not the ones working at the IRS
and the wealthiest doctors are the ones
on social media not even the ones doing
neurosurgery while this inclination was
already taking shape during the Boomer
and the Gen X Generations is escalated
to an unprecedented degree amongst
Millennials before 2000 non-tech people
in inflation-adjusted terms were making
40-60k while tech people were making 70
to 90k some might cross a hundred
thousand but that was pretty much it
today it's still hard for non-tech
people to reach 70 or 90k but tech
people are able to reach 200 500 1
million dollars per year by the time
they're 30 or 40. the disparity between
non-tech and the tech people is no
longer 40 or 50 percent it's straight up
a magnitude and that's no wonder why the
leverage scale and efficiency that's
possible with tech is incomparable to
any traditional job as such their
earnings potential is far higher also
remember all those shortfalls that we
are previously discussing well those are
automatically solved by Tech take Stock
Investing For example if you're in Tech
you're either going to be forced to take
stock compensation whether you like it
or not or you're earning so much that
even if you're conservative with your
Stock Investing it adds up to a
substantial amount also if your degree
aligns with your Tech sector the ROI of
college becomes astronomical and paying
back the debt becomes no problem at all
it's the same thing with the geek
economy while certain gigs like being an
Uber driver might be less appealing
other Tech driven opportunities such as
becoming a YouTuber and during
e-commerce owning Airbnb rentals or
being a remote Tech worker is
extraordinarily favorable the bottom
line is that the modern economy works
for tech people and the people who are
one to two degrees of separation away
from tech for everyone else it sucks and
this is precisely what's manifesting in
Millennial wealth 50 are doing way
better than you think but the other 50
are doing way worse than you think and
that that is the true state of
Millennials AI is no doubt the next
Frontier but I don't think it'll replace
as many jobs as people think check out
this video to learn more but until then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on the
next one